i don't like people who act like they  have a baby they act like they did  something the rest of us can't figure  out like you took a special test or  somebody you can't you anybody can have  one if you can't have one you go buy one  from another country you know  it's like oh i'm a mother now chelsea i  can't i'm a mother  i could have been a mother too okay  three times  and there it is there she blows  we get the obligatory  abortion joke  this is what you always get from  feminist comedians first of all for the  most part they're terrible people so  that's that's that's the first problem i  just want to say that you  are a horrible horrible person they  think that being edgy means simply  saying inappropriate things this is the  edginess of a 14 year old boy  who scribbles the word sex or something  on the bathroom stall and in fact  chelsea handler has it would seem  i'm guessing been inside many um men's  bathroom stalls and that's  clearly where she gets her inspiration